sur bfm paris on a appris qu'une
procédure disciplinaire avait été
ouverte contre un chauffeur de bus de la
ratp
car il les aurait empêché une jeune
femme de monter dans son véhicule à
cause de sa jupe on vous explique tout
cela
la ratp a lancé une enquête sur le
chauffeur de bus qui n'auraient pas
laissé monter une usagère en raison de
sa tenue vestimentaire
les faits se seraient déroulés près du
parc des buttes chaumont selon le père
de la victime présumée sa fille
attendait le bus avec une amie lorsque
le véhicule est arrivé elle n'était que
toutes les deux le chauffeur les a jaugé
n'a pas ouvert les portes hier et a
redémarré la jeune femme de 29 ans
aurait ensuite couru jusqu'à la vitre du
conducteur pour demander au chauffeur
pourquoi il n'ouvrait pas les portes
le machiniste lui a répondu tu n'as qu'à
bien habillé en regardant ses jambes
le conducteur entendu par sa hiérarchie
ne reconnaît pas les faits tels qu'ils
ont été présentés dans la presse il
reconnaît toutefois une faute de service
en ayant refusé d'ouvrir les portes à
deux jeunes filles à une heure tardive
pour le moment aucune plainte n'a été
déposée alors il n'y a pour l'instant
aucun entend pas il n'y a aucun
antécédent dans le dossier du chauffeur
puisque je rappelle que la régie des
transports a ouvert une enquête en
interne que laquelle a lancé également
un appel à témoin il ya eu les vidéos à
bord du bus utilisé le soir de
l'incident peuvent plus être exploitées
parce qu elles sont hors délai 48 heures
sont passées et le chauffeur du bus
accusé reconnaît je cite une faute de
service c'est à dire le refus d'ouvrir
les portes à ces deux jeunes femmes
malgré l'heure tardive mais il conteste
la version des faits pour lui ce n'est
pas parce qu'elle avait des jupes trop
courtes qu'il les a qui le remplit les
empêcher de monter à bord du bus qu'est
ce qu'on l'on pense de cette histoire je
vais demander
commencez par vous jean ici je pense que
c'est une polémique un peu ridicules ont
dû vérifier les faits avant de crier au
loup pour vous on en parle trop vite on
a parlé trop vite et les politiques se
sont empressé de réagir un peu pour
faire le buzz pour faire parler d'eux et
quand on entend ce matin j'ai entendu
chez jean jacques bourdin le délégué cgt
ratp bus expliqué la version des faits
du présumé coupable alors qu'elle est
qu'elle est à lui de dire que ans et
j'ai deux jeunes femmes étaient à la
station de bus et qu'elle était en train
de fumer et n'ont pas prêté attention à
l'arrêt du bus donc le bus a décidé le
monsieur de continuer sa route
et une fois que le bus est parti qu'ils
se sont dit tiens le bus est parti on va
courir après et là il a refusé d'ouvrir
elle n'était pas au bon endroit et est
ce qu'il aurait dit à savoir qu'ils
ôtent premier d'avoir une jupe en plume
un tablier vata billet lui mais l'aja
mais elle elle aurait entendu à travers
la vitre et ce serait le père qui ramait
de la faire devant les médias ce poète
algérien qu'on peut appeler ça comme on
veut
qui se revendique ouvertement sur son
compte facebook islamophobe le disent
que cette religion mortifère va
finalement arrive à des dérivés qui ont
qu'il est contre ça moi ce que je
déplore dans cette histoire c'est le
diktat de l'émotion et que nous ayons
deux ministres d'état la ministre mme
alicia pas qu'ils aient réagi très vite
et la ministre elisabeth baume et ont
réagi lorsqu'on a les faits j'aimerais
qu'elle s'occupe plus vous pour la
sécurité réelle dans les transports en
commun du fait que les transports sont
pas accessibles aux personnes
handicapées que marlène schiappa des
femmes victimes de violence et quand une
femme meurt sous les coups de son mari
tous les trois jours
lorsqu'une femme est violée ne va pas
porter plainte plutôt réagir à une
polémique qui me donne quatre ans est
une chose ça veut dire pour bien résumer
votre propos vous dites il y à la
version qui est porté par la cgt qui y
est qu'il a le porte-voix de ce
chauffeur de bus et qui dit ça ne s'est
pas passé comme cela et il n'y a en
aucun cas une histoire de jupes trop
courtes ou autres parce que si c'est le
cas c'est dramatique si c'est le cas
c'est drame est d'ailleurs quand je
lisais les listes 60 moi je la connais
c'est là où j'ai grandi
c'est pas la ligne de kaboul pour aller
un verger bah oui ni du matin au soir
des femmes qui peuvent être habillés
comme elles le veulent prennent le bus
et pourquoi tu as les merengue lui vient
de me dire pardonnez moi vous êtes en
train de dire ça veut dire que on n'ose
pas dire les on n'ose pas dire et mettre
des mots sur le chauffeur delà de la rlp
mais quand en gros on sous-entendrait
que c'est parce que que c'est sûrement
un sûrement ce à l'infini si demain on
aura les cellules manger ni aux
bordelais ramé des mille la réalité moi
j'ai regardé ce qui se passait sur les
réseaux sociaux
la réalité c'est que ça a été perçu
comme c'est un vilain islamistes qui
refusent une jeune fille ouvrez les
guillemets française parce qu'elle est
en jupe courte en réalité sont tous
plantés
parce que si le vilain islamiste est
effectivement un maghrébin la jeune
fille également été maghrébine donc y
avait pas de racines derrière ça
maintenant faut pas prendre la faire à
coeur comme ça mais ce que tu viens de
dire
c'est en contradiction avec ce que dit
le chauffeur de
de la ratp sida fait une connerie qu'ils
le disent parce que les extrémistes on
n'en veut pas c'est à ce chanteur je
suis désolé jimmy parle du dictats de
l'émotion mais c'est exactement le piège
dans lui-même il tomba l'instant c'est
le piège dans lequel il vient de tomber
je suis désolé jimmy oui c'est vrai ya
des filles à des chauffeurs qui sont
corrects et y en a qui ne le sont pas
également et je ne cherche pas à
stigmatiser vue il ya des endroits moi
j'habite en banlieue et il ya des
endroits où en banlieue il ne fait pas
bon être en gip et où les gens ne se
gêne pas pour vous le faire remarquer
qu'il soit chauffeur qu'ils soient pas
chauffeur qu'il soit vous là les
affaires au voisin mais évidemment mais
madame mais vous avez vu comment c'est
bien ça mais moi on me fait des
réflexions tout le temps dont et je
refuse que jimmy prennent parti alors
qu'on n'a pas encore les fêtes
un appel à témoins qui a été fait on va
entendre les témoignages on sera ce qui
s'est passé mais c'est horrible ce que
tu fais vraiment ce pas bien caroline
alors là moi ça me rend dingue ce qu'a
dit jimmy oui déjà un il mélange tout de
il s'est passé pour le démagogue service
alors que tu viens de dire un nombre de
conneries pardon et je t'aime beaucoup
plus calme à la mort heureusement dieu
l'aimé parce que oui mais attendez grand
du beau tout ça mais bon déjà
premièrement par pardon mais
premièrement bravo à la ratp est ce qu
on peut juste souligné qu' ils se sont
occupés du problème ils sont en train
d'enquêter n'avait pas vraiment le choix
parce qu'il ya eu un post facebook qui a
été repris par tout le monde en
attendant merci les réseaux sociaux pour
le coup pour cette oeuvre pour cette
fois-ci maintenant jimmy mélange tout je
sais pas pourquoi tu prends à ce point
la défense s'est décantée midi après que
quand il me dit après tout c'est d'abord
c'est une parole contre une autre et on
peut peut-être attendre avant de
s'émouvoir de connaître la réalité des
faits et que je vais de mêler deux
personnes et en tout cas dans cette
histoire les deux parties ont se sont
exprimés il ya bien une partie qui est
plus forte que l'autre est en
l'occurrence on a tous envie de prendre
la défense de cette pauvre jeune femme
qui était raison mais pour d'autres
raisons même que lui-même le lundi 17
mai les portes tant il n'est pas ouvert
les portes c'est déjà une fois pour de
ouanaminthe et moi une fake news ou pas
il faut arrêter de se mentir même si on
est aujourd'hui en 2019 je suis désolé
quand une fille se met en jupe et
surtout celle des courtes et savent où
il n'ya pas de collants et surtout s'ils
avaient qu on rajoute des talons on se
fait en merde et on se prend des
réflexions filles en décolleté c'est la
même chose ah oui donc de toutes façons
ça il faut que ça cesse donc il faut
quand même plutôt prendre partie de
cette jeune fille qui se demande
pourquoi elle et pas monter dans le bus
et que lui là c'est toi
non mais je dis ok mais dans la réalité
les choses il ya deux possibilités soit
c'est une affaire d'extrémisme et doha 6
et le deal va être vachement ennuyé et
c'est très grave
soit c'est un fait divers et ça
nécessite pas de mettre une passion
comme ça l'a écouté c'est anormal ce
buzz suivre on suivra la faire et on
verra effectivement laquelle des
versions est retenue avec après cette
fameuse appel à témoin peut-être c'est
dommage effectivement que les services
et une vidéo ne puisse pas être
exploitées 48 heures il faudrait qu'on
commence à ça aussi c'est un complot
avancée quand même eu marre que tout
d'un coup on n'est pas le droit
d'utiliser les vidéos qui est non mais
c'est caroline c'est donc voilà 48
heures c2c hors délai d'un an
il faudrait peut-être que justement la
ratp puisse conserver ses vidéos au delà
de l'examen des cas évidemment la femme
en jupe qui s'est vu refuser l'entrée
d'un bus est ce que c'est scandaleux ou
bien vous pouvez comprendre scandaleux à
92%
effectivement si la version est
confirmée c'est effectivement scandaleux
en tout cas j'en connais on va essayer
de un comédien qui s'émeut fermer
l'accès au bus
mais pour une autre raison
oui oui c'est à m'adapter du camp
japonais ont été conservés au nôtre 48
heures voyez on la conserve